the World Health Organization has
published its list of the biggest health
threats that are facing the world in
2019 and anti vaccine movements have
caused what is being described by the
w-h-o as vaccine hesitancy and it has
made the list of the top 10 health
threats facing the world in 2019 we've
been covering the anti-vaccine movement
for years at this point we've done
multiple long-form videos about it we've
covered individual anti vaccine sort of
enclaves in the United States we've
talked about anti vaccine sentiment from
the left and from the right and that's
an important piece of what is making
this such a big health threat which is
that anti vaccine sentiment exists on
the left and on the right for different
reasons and this is one of the most
interesting elements of the movement
aside from it being horribly destructive
it's also politically interesting
because you have right-wing anti-vaxxers
who are more on the side of wanting a
religious exemption from vaccines or
distrusting the recommendations of a
government for what vaccines you should
get so anti-government ideology is what
causes a lot of right-wing anti-vaxxers
to cattle to coalesce and activate on
the left-wing of politics though you see
distrust of corporations including the
ones that make the vaccines and also
some mistrust more generally of Western
medicine in some enclaves as left-wing
opposition to vaccinations so you have a
coalition of left and right against
vaccines it's still comparatively small
but you see both left and right as parts
of it for very different reasons and
it's ultimately just sad that we even
have to do this story and that this
problem exists but it exists and it's a
huge problem and when we talk about the
measles breakouts that we've seen
whooping cough other conditions related
to the anti-vaccine movement it has now
escalated to a worldwide threat the
percentage of kids who have received no
vaccinations
is quadrupling has quadrupled over the
last 18 years and this is not just a
problem in the United States it's also a
problem in we've talked about it as a
problem in Italy I've read that it's a
problem in Australia we've talked about
some of the other countries where this
is taking hold and it's really important
to understand the company that
anti-vaccine sentiment shares on this
list of the world's biggest health
threats for 2019 Ebola is on the list
dengue is on the list antimicrobial
resistance is on the list a global flu
pandemic is one of the biggest 20-19
health threats to the world non
communicable disease like cancer and
heart disease and diabetes and then you
have parents who choose not to get their
kids vaccinated as one of the biggest
health threats of 2019 this is how bad
it has gotten and although the
anti-vaccine movement is not huge in
terms of its percentage like if you look
at the entire US for example it's a very
small percentage of all parents who are
refusing vaccinations for their kids but
in a country of 340 million people even
a group that as small as a percentage of
the population can still be very loud
they can still have a big impact because
of something called herd immunity within
the world of vaccinations and case in
point if you look at the comments on
many articles about this list that I'm
telling you about today you actually see
outrageous anti vaccine comments there
are thousands of comments saying things
like vaccines are bad I know someone who
got the flu vaccine and three days later
they have the flu that's still something
that people are saying publicly and I'm
not going to do Pat our entire five year
repertoire on vaccines other than to say
that in the world of coherent narratives
anti-vaxxers have stumbled onto a catchy
story and we've talked about this before
Pat you have people on the left and
right who for different reasons are
skeptical of vaccines there are some
conditions medical conditions that we
don't yet fully understand like for
example autism which has become very
popular to blame on vaccines and then
you combine that with social media which
allows the disinformation and
misinformation to spread very quickly
this is the impact that anti-vaccine
movements have now caused vaccine
hesitancy to be on the list of the
biggest health threats to the world in
2019 so I'm not sure if we would
classify anti-vaxxers as conspiracy
theorists although there are certainly
elements of conspiracy to their theories
on vaccines but I wonder if if because
the World Health Organization has
labeled it such a big health threat if
they will actually be reinvigorated in
their views because of that if it would
actually be somewhat counterproductive
because the anti-vaxxer community will
take a look at that labeling and say
look the government's against us here we
must be doing something right yet that
unfortunately we are going to have a
really good long form peace in
partnership with Natanz Natanz notes
YouTube channel about how conspiracy
theories and conspiratorial thinking
works and exactly as Pat is pointing out
here whatever evidence comes forward or
even lack of evidence once someone is
committed to a conspiracy theory doesn't
matter what comes to light it's all
evidence of the conspiracy theory and
that is absolutely going to happen here
and I know that when I talk about this
there's a fraction of our audience that
disagrees with me every time I bring it
up I get angry emails but this is a
blind spot for some people on the left
and some people on the right it's not
something I'm going to pretend isn't
going on and as evidence of how serious
it is the w-h-o which is not making
these decisions politically it's making
these decisions based on the science is
now saying this is a global threat
anti-vaccine movements have become a
global health threat today's program
brought to you in part by Blink accom
slash Pakman blinka
is a great service that i use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information in inside
from each book and I've listened to a
ton of books on blink Asst I recently
checked out soccer na mcc's by Simon
Cooper we do have after all the World
Cup going on recently we also have been
talking about BS jobs and there is a
great new book PS jobs by David Graeber
which I listen to on bling cos they're
constantly adding new books to the
platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I'm putting a link in the
video description and after the free
trial if you'd like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa k ma n